aquí tenemos dos desigualdades esta dice
que x + 2 es menor o igual a 2 * x y
esta en color más o menos púrpura es 3 *
x + 4 mayor que 5 * x y por acá tenemos
cuatro números lo que quiero hacer en
este video es probar si alguno de estos
números satisface a alguna de estas
desigualdades Los invito a que pausen el
video y traten de resolverlo por su
cuenta acaso cero satisface estas
desigualdades o uno lo hace así pues
prueben estos cuatro valores en ambas
desigualdades y suponiendo que ya lo
intentaron resolvamos esto juntos si
probamos el cer0 en esta desigualdad de
acá vamos a sustituir x con 0 tendremos
0 +
2 menor o igual que 2 *
0 esto se cumple del lado izquierdo
tenemos un dos que debe ser menor o
igual igual que 0 y es verdad que 2 es
menor o igual que 0 pues no 2 Es mayor
que 0 Así que esta no es
verdadera este valor no satisface la
desigualdad de la izquierda pero veamos
si satisface la desigualdad de la
derecha para que esto ocurra 3 * 0 + 4
debe ser mayor que 5 * 0 3 * 0 es 0 5 *
0 es 0 así Así que 4 debe ser mayor que
c lo que es verdad este valor s
satisface la desigualdad del lado
derecho ahora probemos con
uno para satisfacer este de la izquierda
se tiene que cumplir que 1 + 2 debe ser
menor o igual que 2 * 1 1 + 2 es 3 menor
o igual que 2 esto se cumple no 3 Es
mayor que 2 esta tampoco satisface la
desigualdad de la izquierda izquierda y
qué pasa con la desigualdad del lado
derecho veamos 3 * 1 + 4 debe ser mayor
que 5 *
1 3 * 1 es 3 + 4 es 7 y 7 debe ser mayor
que 5 y sí en efecto 7 es mayor que 5
Así que tanto c como un satisfacen la
ecuación del lado derecho sin embargo
ninguno de ellos satisface la ecuación
del lado izquierdo veamos qué pasa con
el dos Y aquí es está desalineado un
poquito esto pero recuerden que estamos
haciendo ambas con el mismo color para
que puedan distinguirlas ahora
sustituimos el dos en la x 2 + 2 debe
ser menor o igual que 2 * 2 Así que 4
debe ser menor o igual que 4 y esto dice
que debe ser menor o igual y como está
el igual si se va a cumplir esta si
satisface la desigualdad del lado
izquierdo veamos qué pasa con la del
lado derecho 3 * 2 +
4 debe ser mayor que 5 * 2 3 * 2 es 6 +
4 es 10 que debe ser mayor que 5 * 2 10
bueno 10 va a ser igual a 10 no es mayor
que 10 Así que esta no satisface la
ecuación de la derecha si esta hubiera
sido mayor o igual Entonces sí se
hubiera cumplido si hubiera sido verdad
que 10 es mayor o igual a 10 pero como
no está incluyendo el igual pues esto no
se cumple dos satisface el lado
izquierdo pero no el lado derecho veamos
el último valor el cinco el cinco en la
izquierda es 5 + 2 debe ser menor o
igual que 2 * 5 Así que 7 debe ser menor
o igual que 5 * 2 10 y sí sí se cumple 7
es menor que 10 Así que esto sí
satisface esta ecuación esta desigualdad
de la derecha y seguramente ya se dieron
cuenta de que una desigualdad puede
tener varias soluciones algunas veces no
hay ningún valor que pueda satisfacerlas
pero otras veces hay varios valores que
sí las pueden satisfacer incluso podemos
tener una cantidad infinita de números
que son solución de la desigualdad como
pueden ver nosotros ya probamos varios
números y al menos de este lado
izquierdo dos números no funcionaron
pero otros dos sí fueron solución vamos
a ver el cinco Así que ahora va a ser 3
* 5 + 4 esto tiene que ser más que 5 * 5
3 * 5 es 15 15 + 4 es 19 y esto debe ser
mayor que 5 * 5 25 y pues no estamos
viendo que esto no se cumple así pues 5
no satisface la ecuación de la derecha
De cualquier manera Espero que hayan
encontrado esto
divertido